I forgot to do something.
She gone!
Hello!
Welcome back!
Master!
Lady!
Hello!
Are you monetized yet?
Does it look like I'm monetized yet?
Hello!
I think... maybe YouTube doesn't like me.
That's okay though.
I don't know why you guys are so like...
Get monetized!
It happens when it happens, you guys.
It happens when it happens.
It's no worries.
Welcome to Shinkansen Zero!
Shinkansen...
This is Shinkansen Zero, headed to Tokyo!
That's what it says up there.
I can read.
I can RAID.
Futurama meme.
Yeah.
Cha-ching!
Get monetized!
I haven't seen this Chilla's Art game yet.
Neither have I!
I just know a little bit about it, like I know...
Also, there's an easy mode!
If you make a mistake, you will go back by one.
Card number will not be reset.
Oh, okay.
I didn't really...
There's an easy mode!
Am I in easy mode?
Oh, I forgot to turn on the sound notifications for Donos.
Thank you guys for the Donos.
Give me one second.
Alert box.
Donations.
Not the McDonald's jingle.
Don't sue me.
McDonald's.
Ah, thank you!
Okay.
Since you're such a train otaku, can we get a train sim stream soon?
Oh my gosh!
I think otaku is a hard...
It's like a dramatic...
You know, I like trains.
But to say that I'm a train otaku is...
I think greatly over-exaggerating how much I know about trains.
Because I...
I just like to ride them.
Test.
Thank you!
Here's some bucks until monetization happens.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Train simp.
Yeah, I just like to really ride trains.
So...
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Can you even hear it?
Can you hear the notice?
I guess they don't have to be too loud.
As long as I hear it, right?
I don't know much about JP trains, but...
Is this the type of train that Donna Burke voices?
Yes!
She...
Um, Donna Burke...
Uh...
The...
One of the singers of Metal Gear and the voice of the iDroid.
She also is the voice on the Shinkansen.
Oh.
One of the voices.
I can't...
I...
Oh, gosh.
Nozomi?
Hikari?
All of them?
I don't remember.
But she is the English voice for the Shinkansen.
So if you take the Shinkansen, the bullet train, in Japan, you will hear her.
Yeah.
I did not know that.
Cool.
Yeah!
It's so cool, right?
I rode the Nozomi and heard her.
There you go!
There you go.
That's the Shinkansen.
I haven't...
I've ridden the Shinkansen a couple times before.
Not many times.
I...
I say couple.
Like, maybe four.
Like, one...
Like...
Like, two times?
So, we'll be going there and back.
So, four times total.
Um, but it was before I played Metal Gear, so I never even realized that it was her.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you!
Thank you again for the short karaoke stream yesterday.
I was happy to pull out my King Blades for you.
Thank you.
The train in this game is voiced by Chris Prye.
Aw, man!
I knew it!
BMG before Metal Gear.
We'll build our own mint voice train soon.
What?
I don't even know what they say.
This train is bound for...
Nagoya.
I know more what they say on the normal trains.
What do they say?
The doors on the right side will open.
What if I said it like really crazy, though?
Um, this train is headed to Tokyo.
Um, you can get off whenever you want in between then, I guess.
The next stop is, um, Shinagawa, maybe.
Um, are you sure you don't want to go to Akihabara?
Um, oh, oh, sorry, we're already here.
The doors are opening!
Get out, get out, get out!
Sorry, I didn't buy a ticket.
Get out!
Get out, get out!
Stepped out of moving train.
Uh-oh.
Akiba sucks now.
What the?
I'm putting you in timeout.
How dare you say that in my, in my, in my, in my chat.
Akihabara does not suck now?
How dare you say?
How dare?
How dare you?
We have a, we have a Ikebukuro believer over here.
We have...
We have, we have someone who's just like, Oh yeah, go to...
Go to Sunshine City, it's so much better.
Thank you!
Fun fact, Annaburke also does the English audio for the 2020 Olympic Stadium Tour at the Tokyo National Stadium.
Oh, really?
I guess I'll have to go.
She does something else.
It's her in Nanoha, right?
I don't remember.
Oh my gosh, you guys, thank you!
Oh my gosh.
So many staff!
I mean, I can finally catch a livestream.
I never got to say welcome back.
So welcome back!
Thank you so much!
Our next stop is Tuesday.
The next station is Yureimachi.
The ghost town, for real.
This game is one of those games where you have like the anomalies that you have to spot.
Right?
Pretty sure that's all you do.
You try to escape the train is what I imagine.
I kind of like the ones where you have to find the anomalies.
I actually really like hidden object games and things like that.
So these kind of scratch like a certain itch that I really enjoy.
Like Observation Duty?
I think so.
So...
Is this like the exit game?
I'm pretty sure.
But...
But on a train.
Were you an iSpy book enjoyer when you were young?
Absolute...
Oh my gosh!
You just...
You just unlocked a memory for me.
I...
Another children's game that I would play all the time was the iSpy Spooky Mansion.
Like I...
I didn't own any of the other iSpy games on the computer.
I only owned the...
The spooky...
The Haunted Mansion one.
And I really liked when the skeleton would crawl around.
It was so fun.
Oh my gosh!
Maybe I can find a way to stream that one too.
I'm gonna have to...
I'm gonna have to like buy a Windows 95 computer or something to be able to run these games.
Hmm...
I didn't have the book.
I only had the game.
The computer game.
But it was so fun.
It was so fun.
So awesome.
So thank you for unlocking that memory.
Actually there was like at the end of the game when you beat it, like the skeleton I think he would like crawl out of the chimney.
And I always loved that part.
Spooky skeleton.
Hope you enjoyed this video.
The ghost was cool.
Yeah, he would be in every puzzle.
So fun.
Horror edutainment.
I loved...
I...
I'm telling you.
I don't think I've changed much from when I was a kid.
I've always loved horror so much.
I've always been like this.
Where if something was like spooky themed, I'd be like, that's my favorite.
Halloween was the best time ever for me.
Especially because my parents would get really into it too.
My dad loved decorating the house.
And there was even like some special Halloween decorations that he like created himself.
And then even when I got older, him and our neighbor...
The neighbor...
They would like...
At the neighbor's house, they would help...
My dad would help the neighbor set up a haunted mansion in the neighbor's house.
For like...
Kids to go through and stuff as a kid.
Well, I wasn't really a kid at that time.
But so...
Yeah.
I just had a family that also loved...
Halloween.
So maybe that also influenced me.
I don't know.
I don't really know.
I'm just...
I'm just not like other...
Other ghosts.
I like Halloween.
Okay.
New game?
Yeah.
I haven't started at all.
So there's nothing to over...
Over...
Save.
Whatever the word is.
Whoa.
The sensitivity on this is kind of insane.
Settings of sensitivity.
Let's put it down like here.
Let's do crosshair also.
So you guys can see what I'm looking at.
Okay.
Where's the crosshair?
Never mind.
That was volume?
No.
Are you kidding me?
Oh.
I thought he...
It's so funny because even after I changed it, I was like, that's much better.
Okay.
That's...
That's actually...
That's better.
I...
What's...
Placebo affected myself.
Oh.
That's funny.
Okay.
Oh.
Nothing.
Grandma.
Why does this look so strange?
Oh.
Her phone is literally...
Why does this look?
Why does she look just AI generated or something?
Hey.
It's Matara.
Don't say that.
Rule.
What's the rules?
Hey.
I'm going to Japan around Halloween and I'd love to see an idol show while I'm there.
Any recommendations for beginners?
Oh gosh.
Halloween is like such an awesome time to go because there's so many...
I'm just kidding.
Oh, who's in there?
There's so many shows going on.
It's harder to say, only because I feel like you should...
There's the crosshairs.
It's easier to know the idol group and...
and like find them that way, you know?
Thank you.
Perhaps you'll be interested in playing short horror games from Ichiyo someday.
There's a couple of really good ones.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
For sure, for sure, for sure.
Maybe we can do like a group of like short horror games.
Kind of like play like, I don't know, three or four or something in a stream.
Okay.
I can't see where I'm clicking.
This way, right?
Wait, what if I try opening this one?
Oh, my bad.
Open.
I can't tell.
Is there a crosshair or not?
I'm not crazy, right?
I can't tell where I'm clicking.
I'm just curious.
Oh.
This Home Alone kid.
Oh, my God.
What is this ad?
On the train.
Sorry.
My sound scared me.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh.
Turn back if there is an anomaly.
Speaking of Ichiyo horror games, I would die of happiness if you played Voices of the Void.
Never heard of...
Oh, my God.
Cat Cafe.
You guys, I'm going to be honest.
Cat cafes, I went to a couple while I was in Japan.
And they're just not worth it.
Even, like, it never scratched that itch that I had of wanting cat time.
And usually, the cats are, like, are so uninterested because they're messed with all the time.
You know what I mean?
So, it's just...
There is one that I like to go to called Nekojalala in Akihabara.
It's kind of, like, off the path.
So...
It's good.
Is that a person?
Oh, no.
Oh, there's an anomaly.
Turn back.
So, I go here?
Oh.
Oh, wait.
People aren't anomalies.
You say that.
They are to me.
To be fair, that's how owning a cat is, too, most of the time.
I don't...
No.
My cat is very...
Can I crouch?
No.
Can I run?
I...
Uh-oh.
You can run.
Okay.
I'm a salary man.
Oh, my God.
This guy is balding.
Oh, he kind of looks like broccoli.
Hey, wake up.
Are you an anomaly?
Sorry.
I'm afraid to click on him.
Are you?
Okay.
We're fine.
Run, run, run.
He's gonna chase us.
Oh, my God.
He's chasing us.
Okay.
Are there anomalies in here, too?
Or...
Wait.
Is that suitcase supposed to be there?
I'm sorry.
Oh, my God.
We're real poor.
We're gonna steal the pen.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my Gosh.
Oh, God.
He's using the tablet, right?
Open this case.
Oh, man.
What I see with you today...
This account is having some troubles right now.
This account is far from being locked up.
Oh, hello.
What?
What are you doing there?
Hello!
Thank you, thank you so much.
I'm sorry.
Hello!
Thank you so much.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'm a little jumpy because of the caffeine, I think.
I've heard they don't even serve real cat at a cat cafe.
It's some kind of mock cat.
Stop!
How dare you!
That kid was staring at an anomaly.
Would you be interested in playing Lifeline?
It's a voice controlled horror game.
Clippers will go mad.
Oh!
That sounds fun.
Yeah, I'd totally be interested in that.
Today we learned that kids scare the ectoplasm out of ghosts.
What are you doing?
I'm just, you know, walking between cards.
I'm being a menace.
We meet again.
Wait.
Did you come to play a game?
Wait, looping?
I'm so excited.
Oh, sorry.
I should be reading this.
I think I'm walking a little bit of it.
I'm super excited.
I'm bored because my sister won't wake up.
I was really bored here because my sister's not waking up.
Oh, I wonder why.
No matter how long I wait.
She doesn't seem to open her eyes.
Remint.
But my brother will play the game for me.
I'm fine now.
But now that I have you to play the game, I feel better.
So he's looping also.
Do you know the rules of the game?
I don't know.
The rules are very easy.
The rules are simple.
If something changes, I'll come back.
It's easy, right?
Oh.
See something off in the train?
Turn back.
You know, maybe you should subtitle the whole thing so I know, you know, that you're not gonna keep talking.
Want to finish the game?
That is...
Just go to car 0 and hit the brakes in the driver's room.
Oh.
Get to car 0 and hit the brakes in the conductor's room.
The train in the bathroom won't change.
That explains that.
There are no anomalies in the restroom area.
That sounds... fake.
Why can I open the door then?
If there's no anomalies in the restroom area.
Why can I open the door?
And why is it in green?
Hmm.
Kinda sus.
Do you want me to explain again?
Got it.
Uh, yes, I got it.
That's good.
Good.
I'm not dealing with an idiot.
That's good.
See you later.
I'll see you at the end then.
The end of the world or...
Okay, kid.
And to you too, little lady.
I like her dress.
Looks like something I would wear actually.
But what if it like opens, you know?
I don't know.
Oh.
Eh?
Isn't this the same as before?
Mister.
I'm scared to talk to him.
Now it starts.
Okay.
So...
What kind of thing would count as an anomaly?
Like...
Um...
What?
Are they still here?
I wonder.
Oh gosh.
Looks like an anomaly.
Ah!
Wait, is he...
The kid turned into the blob.
The kid turned into a lump of flesh.
Wait, is this an anomaly?
Or...
Hello?
Is that a person?
Hey, kid.
Are you okay up there?
This is...
Okay.
You know how...
Um...
Tickets are getting more and more expensive for places.
And...
Now...
These tickets cost the same as like a business class.
And this is like the economy.
They're...
They're just...
You know...
They're sticking people wherever they can to make a profit.
So...
This is like...
This is actually our future right here, you guys.
I think I should turn around.
I think that's an anomaly.
And so now it will say six.
Right?
Yippee!
Okay.
Cat cafe.
Headed to Tokyo.
Very good.
Let's see.
Well, it's a good thing we noticed the flesh.
Thing.
Whatever that was up there.
Um...
Ooh.
I'm scared.
Huh.
Hmm.
Numbers are counting.
Seven.
Seven!
Maybe I'm tripping.
Okay.
It's back to being a suitcase.
A sister is still asleep.
Uh...
I don't know.
Nurse?
I don't know how much of this I need to remember.
Oh!
Gosh!
Look everywhere.
Okay.
The numbers are numbering.
Yes.
He got folded like an omelet.
Deep.
Okay.
I think the game...
I think it's just the game doing that.
These look...
Everything looks normal.
Anything under the seats?
Nothing.
Anyone forget a soda in the seats or anything?
This guy still got his shoes...
Oh!
Oh.
Never mind.
Hello?
Oh!
He's awake!
Is he?
Actually...
I can't tell.
Are you?
Okay.
I think we're good.
Take his shoes.
Then it won't be an omelet.
How will we know if it's an anomaly or not if we take his shoes?
One last look of things.
I don't see anything in the windows like if there's a creature following me.
I don't know if that's a thing either.
We continue onward.
No anomaly in this area.
Okay.
If you...
If you say so.
I don't believe you.
What?
What did I miss?
Okay.
No way!
What did I miss?
It looked so normal.
Okay.
It's fine.
We just started.
Whatever.
I don't care.
It's fine.
Check the windows.
I have been looking.
Like, do I have to check each window individually?
Hmm.
It's so quiet.
The ambience is scary.
It scares me.
This is the suitcase and...
She's gone!
She's gone.
Go!
Let's go.
Are we okay?
We have a six!
Okay.
We're going to Tokyo!
Hmm.
He still got his shoes.
Everything seems okay.
The seats are proper.
Oh, wait!
That's so funny.
Okay, she's here!
She's here!
I'm scared.
Headed to Tokyo.
I don't know how small the details will be.
Like these?
Sometimes it's hard to say with these observation games.
Because sometimes they're like, you need to know...
Did I hear a footstep?
No...
I didn't hear a footstep, right?
Okay, let's look at the windows.
Look at my strut!
I'm stuck on something.
Hmm...
Oh, it looks normal!
But it looked normal before, too!
Hmm...
I don't know why I'm so impressed that he is also in this reflection as well.
Maybe because, I don't know...
It's just like a small detail that I didn't think they would pay attention to.
I don't know, I think we're good, you guys.
I think we're good to move forward.
Right?
Yeah, there she is.
She's still asleep.
Hmm...
Reflections...
I've been looking...
Do I have to go down the whole thing?
La la la la la...
Look at me.
I look like I'm so vain.
Like, I just love looking at my reflection.
Like...
Why am I posing for the camera?
Yeah, it looks normal.
Tokyo!
Tokyo calling!
Five!
It looks a little darker.
Is it just me?
Headed to Tokyo.
Do you guys know that song?
Tokyo Calling by Atarashii Gakkou.
Hello, mister.
Just making sure you're okay.
It looks darker here, right?
It definitely looks darker right there.
Maybe that's the anomaly.
I do.
I was obsessed with it for like a week.
Yeah!
It's so good.
When is it?
The game being the game?
And when is it?
Oh, she's here.
No, I think...
Maybe it isn't darker.
Maybe it's my imagination.
Ah!
Five!
Shinkansen Zero headed to Tokyo!
One day...
What if it says, headed to hell?
I feel like one of the anomalies has to be that, right?
I also have a question.
Is this a game where it's always random?
Or is it a game where each level is always the same?
Because I know with some of these, you have to like play them over and over again to see all the different kinds of anomalies.
Oh, it is random.
Cool, cool.
Oh, I'm too afraid to get close to him.
I'm afraid of people.
Okay.
So now, we have to make one... we have to make a lap up and down.
To make sure there's no seat people.
What if he grabbed... what if he grabbed me?
Okay.
Alright.
And...
Let's look this way.
We're looking at the reflections too.
We're making sure there's no one here.
Looking at the reflections on the chairs.
Nothing that I can see.
Okay.
Hello, mister.
Hope you're doing well.
Just stay right there.
Looked like almost Ronald McDonald was in the seat.
Wasn't it?
The guy sitting there last time.
I think we're good.
I think we are okay to move on.
It always feels weirder that there's no anomalies than there being an anomaly.
You know what I mean?
Let's go.
Was that flickering meaning that I messed up?
Am I gonna have to hide in the bathroom at some point?
Oh!
Nice!
Okay, headed to Tokyo!
Alrighty!
Very good!
I like psych myself out.
I'm like, what if he's gonna lunge at me?
What if he's...
Chuu!
The anomaly is there's a cute ghost on this train.
Where?
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
Okay, she's here.
Alright.
There has to be something here though.
Right?
There's gotta be something.
Behind me?
What's behind me?
Where?
Under there.
Under where?
Okay, let's start here.
I think it's the...
The issue is I...
Don't know what all kind of anomalies we can get.
You know?
Uhhh...
Shoe's still on.
Hmm.
Suitcase.
Better not to bring like your suitcase though on.
Because...
You know.
Takes up a lot of space.
It's not such a big one.
I mean you can always store it above too.
Hmm.
Ch-ch-choo.
Choo-choo-choo.
Choo -choo-choo.
Choo -choo -choo.
Choo-choo-choo.
I don't know, you guys.
I think this one looks good too.
Do they serve food on these trains?
Usually, yeah.
But it's not like... you have to buy it.
It's not like an international flight sometimes when they give you food.
Suitcase missing?
No, it's up there.
Someone said one of the lights was flashing.
Is that true?
Or was that just the game being silly?
I'll check again.
Was that the game?
I can't tell if the light adjusting is the game or...
Let's see.
Okay.
Like I'm... Okay.
Getting through these seats.
My god.
See you like that!
See you like...
Okay.
Flashing lights?
Maybe.
I don't know what that would even mean.
Okay.
I think we're good.
I think I'm being a little paranoid, but it's fine.
Oh god!
Jeez!
Okay.
Alright.
It says no anomalies in this area, but I don't believe it.
I think I see the anomaly.
Why does she get to sit down, but he's standing up?
Also, he's huge!
He's ginormous!
Do you think he'll come at me?
Is she looking at me?
No.
Can't tell.
Go say hi.
This kind of looks like the inside of a plane.
He eats his broccoli every day.
I need to clean the middle of the cart a little bit better.
No, she looks the same as before, I think.
She's still, like, moving her head around.
I'm scared!
Is he gonna come after me?
I don't wanna lose!
You guys were on cart two!
We're so close!
Look out the window.
Well, this is just normal.
It's just me.
Oh my god, you can see him standing there, though.
This guy is an absolute unit.
His torso is so long!
Wait, how tall are we?
Okay, I don't want him to come after me, but I wanna compare our heights.
I have a bit of a complex, okay?
Armstrong, real.
Don't turn around!
Don't do it!
His torso is so long!
I just wanna see what he looks like, you know?
Don't look at me.
He's got boobs.
Oh my god!
My curiosity has been satiated.
One!
Baby!
Yippee!
This is Shinkansen Zero, headed to Tokyo!
See, don't you feel more comfortable sitting and relaxing and...
Let's see.
That looks like a suitcase.
Let's get to the end of the cart and assess.
Before we do anything else.
Is there a...
Any other people?
That I might have missed?
Okay, suitcase is normal.
Sister is there.
Sleep.
No one there.
Nurse.
Doctor.
Okay.
He doesn't look that tall when he's sitting down.
Um...
Maybe he has, like, heels on or something.
Don't they make those kinds of...
Gosh.
Those, like...
They...
Don't they make some shoes for guys that, like, don't look like heels but actually are?
Just to give them a couple...
A little boost?
Maybe?
What?
No, maybe...
Maybe I'm just...
I don't know.
Something looked off.
Maybe I'm wrong.
Platform shoes?
I don't know if they're exactly platform shoes, but...
Tom Cruise special?
How tall is Tom Cruise?
I feel very short on this.
Like, my character.
Wait, this looks normal, you guys.
You guys, this looks normal!
What do we do?
It looks too normal!
It looks too average!
The numbers...
What do they mean?
They're...
Oh, yeah.
I see.
This one's kind of flat.
Oh!
Wait.
The...
The lights weren't acting like this before, were they?
Or am I just crazy?
I can't tell.
Like, if they were like that before or not.
Okay.
Check the reflection.
I'm checking my reflection.
There we go.
There were no other people in the scene.
That's right.
I didn't miss any...
I didn't miss anyone, right?
The strut.
I know.
Look at me go.
I look like...
I'm such a child.
I didn't pay attention at all, but I'm just gonna believe...
I can't tell if they were playing it like this before.
Oh, look at that.
Package area.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, look at that.
She went to the healthcare center.
Things like this.
Okay.
Headed for Tokyo.
Yes.
Everything else looks right.
Cat Cafe.
Okay.
I'm getting paranoid.
Right?
I don't know.
I don't know what else could be wrong.
Looks normal.
I think it is.
You guys?
I think this is a plain Jane train.
Whoa.
Oh, my.
Alrighty.
No turning back.
No way.
Headed to Tokyo?
We did it?
Did I beat the game?
Hey kid.
Ugh.
Are we okay?
Everybody?
That didn't scare us at all, did it?
We were fine.
We were totally whatever.
Wait, do I need to turn back on this one?
Are there anomalies here?
It doesn't say if there's an anomaly turned back.
Song suggestions?
I think you'd slay at.
Oh, I do know Melodies of Life!
I'll check it out, thank you.
I've been able to catch many streams due to work.
It's okay.
I've only done like three.
Congrats on another episode of the podcast.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Good luck with work!
Wait, so I can just go forward here?
Just go forward?
Okay.
Ah!
What's happening?
What's going on?
Children?
What's happening?
Where?
What's going on?
What's happening?
Personal?
Oh.
We stopped momentarily due to an injury.
There's no plan for the train to stop at this moment.
Please excuse the delay.
Wait, where did he go?
Attention please.
Oh.
We have stopped momentarily due to an injury.
This is too real.
There is no plan for the train to stop at this moment.
Please excuse the delay.
Thank you!
Wait...
The... the injury?
Was it you?
Please excuse the delay.
Wait, where did...
The injury?
Oh,
I just go inside.
Okay.
Just kidding.
One second...
Clear blue car.
Wait.
What do you mean?
Clear blue car?
What do you mean by that?
What are you... Oh.
Did you wash your hands?
Mister!
Looks like you made it!
Why did you translate this part?
You thought this was the conductor's room?
Oh no, your princess is in another castle!
You're only half way there!
It's the green one?
I never specified which car 0 you have to get to.
Don't you know Shinkansen have green car?
Green's cars.
You know...
Where the premium seats are...
That's literally what I talked about!
The green's cars.
If you're an adult, you should know that.
You have to go through the green cars to get to the conductor's room.
What he says versus what is written here is so funny.
The way he has such confidence in English.
But he was just like...
My explanation might have been kind of bad.
But here he's just like...
Duh!
The confidence they give him is so funny.
Wow!
What's that?
Why is there spaghetti?
I mean...
Spagetti.
Hahaha...
Oh...
Whoopsie.
We have stopped the train due to an injury.
A passenger has suffered shattered eardrums due to high-pitched screaming.
I'm sorry.
By the way...
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
I wasn't listening.
On the green car.
If you can't find it, just go back.
Oh.
When you find an anomaly, go forward, instead of walking back.
Ew, what?
What do you mean?
There's an abacus that will come?
One more thing.
If you make three mistakes, the ghost will get you!
Why is the subtitles, like, not synced with what he's saying?
Hey, mister.
Have you ever wondered why we're here?
Never mind.
What is he saying?
He was just kind of like...
He said basically the same thing as the... as the... the line afterward.
Just to suffer.
I don't know who did the translation, but it's just kind of weird that, like, when he talks, it's, like, a little slightly off.
Let's just clear the game first.
See you at car zero!
Wait, so we have to go to...
I wonder if my sister's awake.
Explain... Oh, no, we don't need him to explain the rules.
Okay.
Wait, so, okay, if we make three mistakes, then...
Turn back if no anomaly.
Wait, no!
Oh, yes, if there's an anomaly, we keep going.
Okay.
What?
Who was that that just sat down?
How do I know if that's an anomaly or not?
I don't know.
Why is she coming towards me?
Lady!
Stay back!
Stay back, I tell you!
Can I get through, or...
Can I get a sandwich, or...
Hello?
Okay.
It's really dark right there where the guy sat down!
It's dark, it's dark, it's scary!
She's working...
I love... we love a business-oriented woman.
It's really dark right there!
I don't like it, I don't like it, I don't like it!
She's gaming.
She's hacking.
I don't like it, I don't like it, I don't like it!
Is it supposed to be this dark?
Why is it so dark here?
I think the lights are actually out.
I think that's an anomaly, right?
Anomaly is forward, so I have to go past him!
I have to go past him!
I have to go past him, Has to go past him, I have to go past him!
has to go past him, I have to go past him!
This is normal!
It is?
The first car is okay.
Okay...
Is it just showing me what's normal...
What's normal?
Are you sure that's normal?!
Are you for real?
Thank you.
I thought you weren't afraid of no ghosts.
I said just a little.
Wait, is that the ghost that will get us if we make the mistakes?
Help him out?
I'll give you a little lift.
Let me, here, let me just tuck my hands under your tushy.
Lift!
Wow, these seats are so nice.
Okay...
The ghost...
I'm not making a mistake, am I?
Wait, oh wait, turn back.
If no anom... wait, so I go this way, right?
Wait.
Okay.
Nevermind.
Oh, it's confusing.
Okay.
I don't like it, I don't like it, I don't like it.
I can't...
I can't tell if you guys are...
if you guys are trolling me or not.
This is normal!
Look at the Terminator up in here, for real!
Then think for yourself.
No, I'm...
I'm trusting you guys.
I'm trusting you.
No anomaly in this area.
What the hell did I miss?
Uh-oh.
Wait.
I missed a shot!
Ah!
Uh-oh.
The ghost is gonna get me.
Oh.
You didn't miss anything?
Okay.
Thank you!
What do you got?
What are you buying?
Damn.
Her...
Her waist?
Damn.
Damn, girl.
I'll buy whatever you're selling.
Gimme them almonds.
Oh, yeah!
Her waist is an anomaly.
Also, oh.
Her toe...
Her toes are really out.
She's like, kind of floating.
That's okay, though.
She's got them...
She's got them Heelys.
Okay.
Oh!
That seems to be an anomaly!
Are you actually spying on me?
Oh, my God.
She did hack me.
She hacked me!
For real!
Why does it look blue on your screen?
Hmm.
Ffff...
Right?
Wait.
Turn back if no...
Right, right, right.
Okay.
Oh!
What is...
Ah!
God, what do you want?
Ha!
Are you human?
No!
Uh...
I hope so.
You can't trick me.
You're wearing a suit.
You're wearing a suit!
It's so in my ear!
That's strange.
You don't act like the others.
That much I can tell.
He's saying that office workers are not human.
Office workers don't deserve human rights.
How long have you been here for, Ami?
You?
We don't know.
How long have been here for.
It could be any of us.
How long have been here for any who?
I don't know.
What if... Oh my gosh.
Here's my game theory.
What if this old man is the one that had the injury, the accident, and he is now dead limbo?
Oh my gosh.
I don't know.
Did you meet anyone in the train?
A boy?
That's good.
From my observation.
And from my 84 years of experience.
Seems like most people here are not actual humans.
This guy is so close.
This is like...
I don't know how actual old people are, man.
He's giving me that lead stare.
He's just like, come on.
The lead paint stare, please, sir.
They never respond when I talk to them.
They're almost like...
Robots.
I know a human when I see one.
So my conclusion is...
Never trust the men in suits.
That lady, she was also wearing a suit.
Now if you'll let me...
I'm tired.
Let me sleep.
Let me just sleep.
He's like acting like we're the men in black or something.
Before I...
Oh.
Before you what, sir?
Oh!
Wait.
What happened to his face?
Sir?
Are you okay?
Oh.
Nah, he's just asleep.
I think we're okay.
Okay.
It does say that there's no anomalies in this area.
So for him to be in this area means he truly is not an anomaly.
I'm gonna grab a cough drop real quick.
So sorry if you hear it.
I think I need one because of how spooked I'm getting.
Wait.
Are any of these open?
Oh, yes, this one is.
Okay.
What flavor is it?
It's just...
It's not really any flavor.
It's just menthol.
Woo!
Cough drop ASMR.
Do you like that?
Do you like hearing me open my bag and have like a little baggie of cough drops?
Like...
Or rather the baggie has other bags of cough drops in it.
And then also some packets of yuzu and...
It's yuzu...
Wait.
Am I going the right way?
Yeah.
Wait.
Am I going the right way?
Yeah.
I came from...
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, God.
I don't like the way it sits every time.
This is some kind of...
You can use the phone?
You can?
Oh, I shouldn't turn back though.
What's that sound?
Okay.
She's doing regular business things on her blue screen.
What if I block you?
Oh.
Okay.
Wow.
Oh.
I was gonna say.
This is something.
I'm customer service.
I don't even have to use my feet.
This is the Shinkansen Zero headed to Tokyo.
Yeah, unstoppable force.
For real.
I don't like this guy.
I don't like him.
Turn around.
Oh my god.
I don't like this part at all.
Chilla's Art heard that song and took it personally.
All these seats have faces on them.
They kind of look like... No they don't.
What faces?
I don't see anything in the... What is the bar?
Maybe it's just a reflection of the light.
Oh, it's so... Wait.
Okay, that's also a reflection.
I thought I saw like someone leaning out from a seat.
I think this is normal.
This seems pretty normal.
The back of the seat looks like a robot face.
Oh, it does kind of look like a robot face.
Yeah, I see that.
Okay, so I have to run back.
Wait.
What's that light right there?
Is this usually on?
Wait.
Is this in an... Wait.
These are... These are... These are...
Seat lights?
Wow.
That's normal?
Okay.
Turn back if no anomaly.
So we're turning back.
Okay.
What kind of sandwich is this?
Chicken.
Green.
What is chicken and green?
Sea lantern blocks.
Didn't the lady have a blue screen on her laptop?
She did!
That's why we're good.
Because it's a blue screen.
She's literally doing nothing.
Ma'am?
Who are you typing to?
She's got... She's got, like, the special vision.
Oh my gosh.
She's got on Google Glass.
We just can't see it.
And it's... That's why she's typing actually.
Oh, she's got them Apple goggles.
Hope I didn't just make a mistake.
25 left.
You know what's funnier than 25?
26.
25 left.
No one's in here though, right?
Wait.
Okay.
Okay!
Good!
Arigatou!
Wah!
Thank you for the Akadono!
Thank you so much!
Just wanna say that I appreciate you and to not let the rather negative messages you've been receiving get to you.
For every bad message, there are 100 of us that love and support you.
Anyway, best of luck.
You're doing great.
Thank you so much!
Thank you.
Appreciate it so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay, so far so good.
Ma'am, we'll let you pass.
You shall pass.
Wait a second.
Sticks?
You weren't selling sticks before, were you?
Actually, I think she was.
I can't remember though.
I can't remember actually.
Chicken and green...
I feel like if it's...
That looks...
Down there, that looks like a tomato...
Tomato.
Tamago.
An eggy sandwich.
I didn't just say tomato for no reason.
It's because I was thinking tamago.
But...
Oh man.
That's how my brain works.
For real, you guys.
My brain can be quite confusing.
Oh, gosh lady.
Your dumpy is making it hard to pass.
Tomato.
Tamago.
Gosh.
I don't like you.
Wait, didn't he say don't trust the people in suits?
But they're not wearing a suit.
So...
This shinkansen...
Zero headed to Tokyo.
It looks like Orochimaru.
It does, actually.
Anime Oro...
Oh wait.
Anime Orochimaru.
No, Anime Terminator is what I was thinking.
Wait, this one looks too normal too.
Is this combat- Is it working?
No.
Hahaha.
Ah, la la la la la...
La la la la la la la la la la...
La la la la la...
I'm afraid that I'm going to miss something because it's in the dark area and I don't want to go over there.
I'm afraid of the dark you got.
Wait.
Did the cushions always look like this or am I going crazy?
Did the cushions... they did?
Okay.
No and yes.
Why are you like this?
Is it normal then?
Are we normal?
Is everything normal?
Nothing is normal about this.
What is it normal?
Oh gosh!
My throat is actually starting to hurt.
I need to stop screaming.
Mister!
Why is your eye glowing?
Thank you!
I like to think that when the You're a simp sound plays, it's you guys calling me a simp.
Which is quite honestly accurate so...
Looks good to me, Kappa.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
That... I don't believe that there are two trains in a row that are normal.
That's right.
Right?
Like that doesn't sound good.
I'm being serious here?
Go.
I know you can make it.
Get outta here.
Everyone's waiting for you.
She didn't change the bright blue desktop wallpaper.
I didn't either.
Great job, Mer.
I don't see anything in the reflections.
I think we're good.
Oh no, please, no mistake.
I'm afraid of the ghost!
There can only be one ghost here, okay?
Where did Grandpa go?
Oh my gosh, there actually was nothing.
Headed to Tokyo.
25, 25, 25, back home.
25 off this train.
Need you, get out of here.
Is that just the lighting or what is, what is that?
Is that a, what is that?
Is that an anomaly?
Is that a person, what is that?
Invisible man?
I have to go past it!
Invisible man anomaly?
Well, he's not doing a very good job.
I noticed him immediately.
Ma'am, ma'am, ma'am.
What did I just hear?
Ma'am, ma'am, ma'am, there's a man in my seat.
Please, please, there's a man in my...
Oh my gosh, that scared me.
I thought she responded.
One time, okay, so...
I once...
Okay, so one time I flew business class back from Japan.
It was the only time, it's the only time I've ever flown business class on a flight.
And I only did it on the way back home because doing both ways would have been so expensive, right?
Whoa, fancy, I know.
It was after a work trip, so...
I was like, you know what, I am gonna get the business class cause I'm...
I've been working this whole time and I'm very tired.
I just really wanted to, like, feel good on the plane.
And I sat down in my little cubicle.
And also I was just like, this probably will be the only chance I get at business class.
Cause usually they're, like, full.
Like, I just like to check anyway, even though I'm not gonna get it.
But usually all the seats are taken.
But for this flight, they weren't.
And so I was just like, you know...
Slash the price in half.
And my old company had taken care of the initial price.
So it almost felt like I was paying for just a regular ticket to Japan anyway.
So I was like, okay.
So, I know.
It's like, sounds like copium.
But I really had to, like, do some mental gymnastics to get myself to buy this thing.
So, girl math.
Yeah, actually.
The old company being heaven.
Yes.
But anyway.
So I...
I sat down in my little cubicle.
And I'm like, okay.
This is so...
Oh my gosh.
Like, my first...
This is a first time experience.
This is so crazy.
And I lean back in my seat.
And to my right is a man's foot.
The guy behind me, like, put his feet up over the cubicle.
So that his feet were directly in my face.
And I was like, this is...
I did not spend this money.
Well, like, you know.
But I did...
I...
I am in...
I am in the business class.
I do not deserve this disrespect.
So I called over a flight attendant.
And I was like, I know we haven't taken off yet.
But can you tell him to, like, put his feet down?
Also, I was like, the beds go down.
Like, there's so much foot space down there.
Why don't you just lay down if you want to extend your feet like that?
Did you tell him off?
No, because I'm very non-confrontational.
But I told the...
I told the flight attendant.
I was like, could you please tell him to, like, put his feet down?
They're in my face.
And she goes to him.
Thank you so much!
She goes to him and says, the girl in front of you complained.
Could you please put your feet down?
And I was like, now you're gonna...
Now you put a target on my back.
You couldn't just say, hi, sir.
We're about to take off.
Could you please lower your feet?
Like, anything like that?
No!
Yeah, she put me on blast!
I was so...
I was like...
I thought, this is gonna be the worst trip ever.
I should have never paid for it.
Anyway, this invisible man, for some reason, reminded me of that.
Okay.
We just gotta run forward.
We just gotta run.
Run.
He's probably just gonna stay there.
He's...
He's in his own lane.
He's living his invisible life.
He doesn't even want to be seen.
So he wouldn't chase after me because he doesn't want us to notice him.
Anyways.
Maybe I should have publicly shamed that man.
Been like, your feet are stinky!
and they're in my FACE!
Okay.
Moisturized.
And unbothered.
I hope he's not moisturized.
Okay, here we go.
Sorry.
I know I'm like... stalling.
I'm scared.
I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared...
Confirmed that it was an invisible man.
But that thing has never been there before, so...
Oh my god, it's beautiful!
Wait, there's nobody here though.
Oh, that's my feet.
I was like, I like this one.
Wait, we have to continue on through this.
I was gonna turn around, but...
We just gotta... wait, is that a person up there?
No, that's a... wait, that's a tree.
No anomalies, just rad.
Yeah.
Well, at least it was easy to tell.
I'm still kind of scared though.
What if a lion pops out at me or something?
I don't know.
Okay, run!
Hey, it's a kid!
Hey mister.
Do you think we can go back alive?
Do you think we'll ever get out of here alive?
Think about your sister.
Well, I'm gonna keep doing my job.
Maybe you should consider doing yours, okay?
Wow.
That is a trunk.
Anybody in here?
I was wondering if we were gonna see him again.
I thought he would be, like, in the bathroom.
25?
Oh, 24.
It's a good thing that I... that I...
Okay.
It's a good thing I clicked on it because I really thought it was 25.
Can we go back to the pretty car, please?
Can we go back to the nice car?
Well, one thing I can be... I can feel safe about is that nothing will come running from that direction because we have to go forward.
Shouldn't it be 23?
Wait, what do you mean?
24 is not as funny as 15.
Number 15.
Tomato sandwich.
Okay, nothing.
Oh, I thought she was about to look at me.
Nothing in the... reflections that I can see.
Hello?
I mean, I can see the... I can see the mountains from here, though.
Nothing.
Nothing here.
I can't tell if it's the game or not.
Mister,
you need some help?
Thank you.
Glad to have you back, boss.
Any chance you'll play Kojima's masterpiece, Death Stranding, in its full glory on stream?
I would like to.
Just because I want to get ready for Death Stranding 2.
Why does it feel darker than before?
Why does it feel darker than before, you guys?
You guys?
I know it's not, but I think it... I don't know.
I don't know.
He's not balding.
An anomaly.
He has like, luscious.
Beautiful hair.
He looks fine.
He's just a jolly guy.
He's fine.
He's handsome.
Don't worry about it.
I'm on your side, mister.
I'm not gonna let these people bully you.
Headed to Tokyo?
Am I just getting really lucky with these or what?
Wait, let me make sure there's no one sitting in these seats.
He's got a suit on.
Yeah, we can't trust him.
But that doesn't mean... you know...
Okay, I'm gonna move forward, but I'm gonna let you guys decide, okay?
You guys tell me if there's...
Anything, okay?
I'm too scared.
That man is my spirit animal.
I'm also bald.
He's not bald.
He's balding.
I'm scared.
Okay, forward.
Forward.
Okay, it's still there.
It's still there.
Okay, thank you guys.
Thank you.
You really saved me.
Okay.
Turn back if no anomaly.
Good job.
Good job, team.
What would I do without you guys?
Oh, God, please.
I need a break.
I just...
Oh, man.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Car 1.
This is Shinkansen 0.
Headed to Tokyo.
Okay.
Good work, boss.
No, that was on you guys.
That was all you.
Oh, she scared me.
She scared me.
Mmhmmmm.
She's still typey-top.
Okay.
No one else in these seats.
Phew.
What are you working on?
She's writing fanfiction...probably.
I think that's just the game.
Okay.
Alright guys...so far so good.
The other one...the other one could have been easy to miss though.
You know?
Had I...had I not gone back so...
This train is so chill.
You think this is chill?
Are you feeling really relaxed right now?
Are you having a good time?
I'm so happy for you.
You think this is a nice, chill little run here?
Hmm?
Yeah?
Oh god.
Okay mister...
Wait, I don't see anything for real though.
Chilla.
Oh gosh.
I feel so stressed.
I feel very intense.
I feel like I need...like a massage after this or something.
She's so tall too.
How...how...
How short are we?
It's okay though.
I prefer tall women, you know?
It's okay.
Um...
Ghost massage.
Yeah.
Put my...you know, by the time I'm done I'm gonna be like a little ghost orb because I'm gonna be so relaxed.
I'm gonna be...
They're gonna knead me into a ball.
The ball.
You guys think it's okay?
I didn't see anything...
Gosh.
Every time it does that.
That's...that's part of the game.
That's...that's not like an...
I think it would be more obvious if it were like a flickering light, you know?
Looks okay to me.
Turn back if no anomaly.
I think there's no anomaly.
What do you think, ma'am?
Check the old man.
There's no face in his bald spot.
He looks the same as before.
He looks pretty much the same.
He is so tall also.
Maybe I'm the child.
Okay.
Don't look at me.
Here goes nothing.
24.
22.
22?
The numbers.
What do they mean?
Zero!
Oh my gosh, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Good job, everybody.
Good job, team.
Okay.
So far...
So far, so good.
He's always said 22.
What do you mean?
No, I know.
Oh, wait.
He did say 25 before.
Because I said...
Good luck.
Need you...
Go...
Need you go off the train.
Yeah.
He did say 25 before.
I'm not crazy.
They put me in a room.
A room full of rats.
The rats made me crazy.
I was crazy once.
They put me in a room.
A room full of sticks.
The sticks made me crazy.
But we did skip 23.
Yeah.
Unless I just forgot to...
I forgot to...
Your cue.
Crazy.
Cue...
Stop it.
Unless I forgot to check the telephone at that point.
Okay.
Where's rule 7?
Rule 7 is...
what you imagine it to be.
you know, what you make of it.
Ghost of rule 7.
So far, nothing in the windows.
Nothing in the seats.
Ghost in the streets.
Ghost in the sheets.
Ghost in the seats.
That ghost...
What was that sound?
I don't know.
You'd think I would get used to it, but I'm not!
I just think at some point they're gonna grab me.
No way, there's no anomaly on this one either.
Is that common for people who have watched other people play this game?
That there's like, typically...
more anomaly-less trains than anomaly-filled trains?
No, your luck is ridiculous?
Well, if it grabs you, it'd be an anomaly.
So true!
You're cute today too.
No, no, no.
Okay.
This is Shinkansen Zero.
Headed to Tokyo.
Tokyo calling.
Um...
Okay.
Thank you, thank you.
If no anomaly turned back...
It would really suck since we're at train zero!
Right?
Right, lady?
She's kinda double-jointed, just like me.
Rule 7 is rule 30...
No!
That's not an anomaly, right?
That's just a...
I think that's just how...
She looks.
Her face is a bit weird.
Actually, this is maybe the most normal faces I've ever seen in Chilla's Art Game.
Like, ever.
Ever, ever, ever, ever.
I think this is actually the most normal faces I've ever seen in a Chilla's Art Game.
They even have like...
She has a little bit of definition.
Like, I think in the past they've just been like PNGs pasted on top of a... of a... of a... of a egg.
And that was their face.
Yeah, true, they're improving.
Yeah, yeah, she doesn't look so bad.
Like creepy, yes.
And also she's got like these weirdo pixelated shadows.
But that's fine, that's fine.
What's her skincare routine?
For real?
Okay.
I think... I think...
Alright guys, what's the consensus?
Do we...
Do we say there's no anomaly?
I don't see anything.
We went through every seat?
I truly didn't see anything.
I think it's good.
All clear?
I'd say there's none.
Okay.
Still nothing in there.
Alrighty.
Conductor's room!
Nice.
Good job everybody.
Wait, so...
How does this one work?
I still go back if there's an anomaly?
Or...
Or do I just go forward?
Oh gosh, you scared me again.
Just go forward now.
Oh, so there is no anomaly.
Just go to the end?
Just go forward?
Oh madam.
I love to see you walk away.
Headed to...
Tokyo.
So there's no anomalies here?
I can just go?
Even with her?
With him?
Ghost on bottom left.
I think I'm gonna run for it.
Conductor's room.
I can't tell if I...
I believe you guys.
I'm just gonna do a quick sweep.
Just...
A quick check.
Just in case.
Just go forward?
Okay, fine.
Fine.
Doesn't work.
Wait, what's over here?
It's...
It's a PNG.
I'm putting a break...
I'm putting a stop to this...
Crazy train.
Uh oh.
Why am I so small?
Wait, we can go out or we can go through here?
Oh!
Ending 1!
Get off the train!
Song is safe to use on Youtube.
That...
What song?
Wait, so...
What's the other ending?
Wait, what even happened?
Nothing even happened.
Huh?
Uh...
I... Huh?
What about the kid?
This is the normal end.
Oh, wait.
I got the bad end?
Okay.
Interesting.
So there's...
Wouldn't the bad end be dying?
To the ghost?
I do kind of want to see what happens if you mess up three times, but...
Yay!
My favorite song.
I don't know.
Do I want to play it again?
I feel kind of unfulfilled, but...
I have to go through it all over again.
I got really lucky this time where we really didn't make that many mistakes, so...
But I kind of went really slow because I was scared.
Continue from the stop?
Oh, there's a checkpoint!
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, hold...
Space key to skip.
Okay.
Wait, so where should I continue from?
Train... from the green train?
Or...
Wait, after...
After stopping the train...
Thank you!
That was the bad end.
You walked into the light.
You have to go back.
Okay, so after stopping.
Okay, okay.
So here I go forward, right?
I don't go into the light.
I'm scared.
It's so quiet.
What is that?
Wait, there's something in the...
Oh, just kidding.
Maybe the grandpa or the kid are in here?
Okay.
Keep going forward, okay.
I am.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
It's both vacant and occupied.
How is that possible?
Oh!
Just kidding.
Was it like that the whole time?
The phone is also gone.
Thank you for the...
Oh, no.
Thank you.
Don't forget the supporter content section.
To see all the VTuber references on one train car.
I...
I didn't turn the supporter stuff off.
So I think I just didn't see them.
Do I just keep going?
How far do I need to go for?
Schrdinger's bathroom.
Okay.
Just go?
I'm going.
Is there anything in here?
Grandpa?
Kid in the bathroom?
No one in the bathroom.
I don't even know why I'm going back through here.
All the way back?
Oh.
Was that suitcase there before?
Okay.
I'm just going to run for it.
You
have to walk all the way back to your seat.
If you want to see the supporter stuff.
I think you either choose supporter stuff...
Yeah.
But is that the only reason you guys are having me walk all the way back?
Or is it actually the way to get the other ending?
Because...
Ah...
Yeah...
I'm going to check the bathroom every time.
Still not there.
I should probably like check on...
Check in these corners too.
Just in case.
Okay.
Other ending.
On four.
There were seven, right?
I really have to go all the way back?
Yeah?
Chuuu.
Uh.
Hold on.
Give me one second.
I'm going to do something real quick.
Na na na.
Na na.
Okay.
Um.
Meow.
Do I have to check the bathroom every time?
Or...
Or can I...
Um.
Ignore it.
Yes?
So many people...
Some people say yes.
Some people say no.
Why are you checking it even?
In case the kid is in there, right?
Always check the bathroom.
Oh.
She's awake.
Hello?
Oh.
She's like, where's my brother?
Loading.
I see.
Okay.
This train didn't stop.
It was looping.
She sounds so cute.
So the train wasn't stopping and it was looping?
But I was able to stop this train.
Actually, I also just noticed that their mouths move now too.
Before...
In old Chilla's Art games, since it was just the P&G face, their mouths wouldn't really talk.
Right?
And he managed to hit the brakes and stop everything?
That's what she just said.
It turned off again.
Everything about this is so hard to believe.
Oh.
Oh my god, she's so cute!
I guess I have no choice but to believe you.
That is not what she said.
It feels weird.
I don't remember.
Something doesn't feel right.
I don't remember getting on this train.
I don't remember boarding this train.
Boy in a black hoodie.
Oh, I saw your brother?
That's probably Naoki.
Oh, Naoki!
I'm sure he was with Naoki before he lost his memory.
I was with my brother before I lost my memory.
Why are you here?
Did you say anything?
God, she's so cute.
Did he say anything about why we're here?
No.
You didn't see him?
You are...
You weren't with him?
Did you see him on the way here?
Oh, not after I stopped the train.
So you came from the green car side.
Then he must be on the other side.
Alright then!
Let's find him and get out!
Oh.
Wait a minute.
Okay.
Why isn't that part subtitled?
If you think about it, there's a possibility that someone will come here again.
What do you mean by that?
Come to think of it...
I feel sorry for him.
Oh, I guess that's true, yeah.
What about the people who might end up here in the future?
Shouldn't we do something about this train?
Dot, dot, dot.
Wait a minute.
Did you guys need subtitles for that one actually?
Shouldn't we think of a way to end this nightmare for good?
Let's burn it down!
Let's burn the train!
A looping place.
I saw this in an anime...
Come on, girl.
You know what you wanna say.
It's just like one of my Japanese anime.
Oh, I remember.
In the show...
They ran in a really fast direction in the other direction and broke the loop.
They broke the loop by having two people run in the opposite direction REALLY FAST.
THEY BROKE THE LOOP BY HAVING TWO PEOPLE RUN IN THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION REALLY FAST.
Huh?
Jujutsu Kaisen reference?
Oh, actually...
I only watched season 1 of Jujutsu Kaisen.
How was it?
How about that?
But the train isn't looping anymore.
Right, the train stops looping after hitting the brakes.
Oh, I know!
What if we start the train at the same time?
Why are we starting the train again?
From both ends.
You can go back to the green car side.
I'll go to the normal car side.
Why is there a... wait, I'm confused.
Why would there be a way to start the train on this side?
And also, we're closer to the normal car side.
So you're having me run all the way back?
No, I'll go to the normal side.
Wait, uh-oh.
Wait, does this affect the ending?
Uh-oh.
Go to the normal side?
Normal or you get the same ending?
Oh, okay, okay.
Thank you guys, thank you.
Go to the normal side or you get the same...
Okay, thank you guys, thank you!
Oh, I just saw it.
The other ending is...
Back to your seat and choose to go to white car.
The supporter stuff isn't related to the very start of the game as an anomaly.
Ah, got it, got it, got it.
Understandable.
Thank you.
Okay, so I'll go to the normal side.
Is that so?
Are you sure?
I think my brother is on the normal side.
My brother is on the other side.
I'm going to have to leave my brother to you.
Can I trust you with my brother?
Leave it to me.
But you were able to stop the train.
Yeah, I'm competent.
Well, you did manage to stop the train.
Understood.
Alright then.
Then I'll leave my brother, Naoki, to you.
I trust you, mister.
Let's do our best together.
Yeah, alright then.
Let's hurry.
Before this train starts moving again.
Who knows when the train will start again.
Okay.
Let's go.
Let's hurry.
That's what you said.
Come on.
Let's hurry.
Get running, girl.
Get running.
Where's the kid?
What just happened?
Hello?
Oh, it's not even...
I don't think it's letting me.
I'm scared.
What's gonna happen?
Is someone gonna chase me?
I swear.
If you come trying to chase me, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna do something.
You're not gonna like it.
Run?
Okay.
I'm running.
Why?
Are they already chasing after me?
I don't hear anything though.
Are they like an invisible force chasing after me?
Okay.
I'm running.
Go go go go!
There's the music!
What's chasing me?!
Oh
it's shrinking!
It's shrinking!
Oh my god!
It's still shrinking!
Oh no no no no no no!
It's crushing!
Oh my god!
No, no, no!
No, no, no, no, no!
Oh my god!
Oh!
It's just like in my nightmares!
Ah!
Oh!
Whoa!
Woo!
It's beautiful!
Wait, we're in the actual normal world!
We made it back?
Maybe?
Oh my gosh!
Oh!
Maybe we're not in the normal world.
Actually, I'm not so sure.
Um, hmm.
I love my void trees.
You know?
Uh, oh wait.
Uh, wait.
Where's the door here?
Oh, I can't go out?
Okay.
Oh!
Oh my god!
We made it!
Oh!
And...
Ah!
Sorry!
Ow!
Onii-san, you're here!
I've been waiting for you!
Freaky ghost!
Onii-chan, you're here!
You woke up!
Naoki!
I'm glad you're safe.
You're okay!
Onii-san, I'm okay now.
I'm fine now, Mr. That's right!
Onii-san, do you want to come with us?
You want to come with us?
Oh!
I only have... No, not yet.
That's right.
You're right.
I don't think you should come.
It's not your time yet?
Am I dead for real?
I don't know.
I think I know what happened to us.
Don't worry.
Wait, so...
But they're gonna come back to life, right?
It's okay, mister?
Or they are... they're the dead ones!
I think, actually, they're the dead ones.
More importantly...
We have to get home.
Thank you, mister.
And goodbye.
Oh my god.
Thanks, kid.
Don't go breaking your arm for me.
No, I think...
I think they're the dead ones.
I can feel it as a ghost.
I get that sense from them.
I fell?
Oh!
Wait!
Remember when the...
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you so much!
Remember when we had the train stop because of the personal injury?
You were collapsed on the floor.
Luckily, there was a doctor on board.
That does not sound real.
It seems you were suffering a light form of deep vein thrombosis.
What?
That's a voice.
Or what the lemans call it, economy class syndrome.
You guys, I called it from the very beginning that this was a game about the rich.
They actually did stuff our body up in there.
I can't believe it!
I was right this whole time!
For some reason, I thought we were in the bathroom and I was like, please do not lay me on the ground in the bathroom.
Also, are they like on little stools?
I thought they were crouched at first, but it looks like they have little tiny benches.
Laying down and raising the legs seem to have helped.
You should be thankful he was here.
Oh my gosh.
It would have taken much longer to get help.
Because the train had also stopped while you were out.
Because of that accident, this train has stopped for a while.
Oh.
She said the personal injury.
It stopped because of the personal injury.
Excuse me.
This is a business call.
What is she, your mom?
Right!
Reporting.
It was confirmed that a young woman and a boy were involved in the accident.
Oh, that was the injury.
Okay, wait.
Are we the injury?
Oh no.
A young woman and a boy were confirmed to be involved in the accident.
Over.
Oh.
I knew they were dead.
And I was almost dead too.
Because I had to sit in an economy.
Ending to sad reality.
That's why you got hit.
Don't go walking in the middle of the train tracks.
Uh.
Oh.
Here's our song.
Ah.
Economy seats were too uncomfortable.
Look at that guy.
We saw him, right?
We saw him in the first class.
He literally was making fun of us.
It's always interesting seeing what VTubers are in the credits.
Maybe one day I will be in the credits.
I know I would have to do it myself.
Like I know I have to subscribe to the Patreon.
But maybe I'll do it one day.
I think every time I play one of these games, I say I'll do it.
And then I forget.
And then I forget completely.
Champ's company, why are you so...
One day.
Yeah.
One day I will be a supporter too.
I say that.
I say like one day as if like it is this great honor.
Even though it's just something I need to do myself.
Okay.
Next game, guys.
Next Chilla's Art game.
I'm gonna put my name in the game.
Okay?
I think I belong there because I'm a ghost.
Yeah, you just pay up.
Exactly.
I just have to remember to do it.
I always forget.
Though I... Thank you.
Deep vein thrombosis means having a blood clot in your leg veins.
Most often, which can happen due to sitting too much.
If not treated, it can be fatal.
Or cause loss of limbs.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, actually?
This song is so fine.
I like it.
I saw that there's a way to put yourself as a character in the game.
Can you imagine if I was one of the ghosts?
Wouldn't that be so fun?
Wouldn't it be so fun if I was chasing after you?
I'm gonna ask her to be like, Hey.
Oh, it is?
It was an actual movie.
A sponsor?
Hey...
You were Orochimaru.
I'm just chillin'.
I'm chillas.
I'm chillin' in the sea.
That one...
I think...
Um...
Actually, what happened in this is what kind of...
Gets me about these...
Find the...
Find the anomaly type of game.
You know what I mean?
So...
I love these types of games, but because they're randomized you can get a lot or you can get a little.
And so...
Um...
Mmm...
So... Yeah...
I don't know.
I...
Um... I still liked it.
Just felt like maybe we didn't get some of the more interesting...
more interesting anomalies.
Maybe.
Like, gotcha.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
But we got pretty lucky in that we could finish it, like, without much error.
You can continue and find the anomalies.
That's true.
Continue supporter... You guys really want me to do the supporter content.
Oh my gosh.
Calm down.
Oh, that's cute though.
The way that they just have it like all...
like just...
here...
They're just like...
It's all... It's all just laid out.
Wait, so is there... Is this...
Is this just...
There's no anomalies?
It's just looking at the supporter content?
I guess this is a cute way of doing it.
Especially... Oh my god!
Oh, he's... I forgot he was here!
Wait... Oh!
They go all the way down?
Oh!
I feel like this would make more...
Oh my god, so cute!
I feel like this would make more sense in the...
What's it called?
Pick things up?
Cute!
Oh my gosh, so cute!
My throat hurts from screaming.
That's so cute!
Oh my gosh!
So cute!
You guys, I found out something that made me so sad.
Okay, so I love eating Inari Sushi.
And I was like...
I was like, this is healthy, right?
It's tofu!
I mean, I know it's fried tofu.
But like, it's tofu.
And then I googled it, and they were like, Inari Sushi is really not good for you because of the oils, and this and that, and this and that, and I was like...
But it's like...
It's so delicious!
Healthy, it's so oily.
I never thought of it, okay?
I never thought of it.
Like...
I wanna see the sandwich.
Oh, nevermind.
Helsing game?
Like, Helsing the anime?
I like the train.
Hey Chillizart, put me on the train.
The Edo train.
I can't even read this one.
It's so small.
Get off today!
Oh my gosh, Winter Cedar, no!
I wanna donate while I can.
What?
No!
Oh my gosh, no!
Is there something on the suitcase?
Oh gosh!
There is...
Oh my gosh, there's little chinchillas under the sea!
That's so cute!
I wish I could crouch.
Eww.
Scary.
Inuyama Tamaki!
Cute.
I think Tamaki-san has been in like every game ever.
Or every Chillizart game that I've seen.
I think he's been in every single one.
For as long as I can remember.
Hahahaha!
Uh...
Mlekka movies.
This is making me hungry.
Hot coffee.
Oh cute!
Ronald McDonald!
Hahahaha!
That's so cute!
Ronald McDonald!
Very delicious!
Oh!
It's Iris!
Hahahaha!
Wait, wasn't Ollie in another game?
Wait, this one's so funny.
The way she's like squished against the can.
Iris cider.
Uh...
Oh, it's a song.
Cute.
Nabu nabu bento.
Hi Iris!
It's Iris!
Uh...
I can't grab the...
Oh my gosh.
No wonder.
I couldn't...
It's just like a couple.
They're just bragging.
All that effort just to see a damn couple.
Good for you.
You've missed a few of the stars.
I know.
I'm gonna go back.
Hahahaha!
That's uh...
I want that exact same type of energy.
If I am in the game.
That's the kind of picture I'm gonna send in.
Yeah, I'll go back and look at some of the other ones.
Are these Korean VTubers?
A cute vanilla strawberry.
Cute.
This is making me hungry, you guys.
All I had was cereal.
Oh, cute.
Mmm...
Peach tea.
Lots of people just leaving their garbage everywhere.
Rainbow ice.
Cute.
Ume drink.
Where did I... I don't even...
Oh...
What is going on here?
Where did I... Where did I start?
I don't remember.
Oh my god, cute!
Duh!
Neko ice!
Hahahaha!
I think we saw something very cursed.
I think we saw something that we shouldn't have.
That... Oh!
That was the anomaly.
Oh, we saw these ones.
We saw...
Did we see this one?
Yeah, yeah.
We saw these.
Did I see this one?
No, cute.
Ahem.
Gyutang.
Do you guys like gyutang?
Have you ever had gyutang before?
Cow tongue.
I'm not such a huge fan.
Are there more cars?
I don't think so.
Actually, I say that.
I have no idea.
Oh, nope.
Where did I leave off?
I heard it's good.
I don't like really chewy meat.
You might not like it either.
The taste is good.
But it's super...
So that's why I don't like it.
Sam?
Yeah.
Oh, wow!
Siobhan!
Work it, girl!
Get your face on the bento.
Hell yeah!
That's so funny.
Latte rich.
Oh, cute!
Cute.
Do people typically go through these?
Is this it?
Is this why you guys wanted me to go through the entire train?
Is this why you berated me to look through the supporters?
That's really clever, actually.
The fact that she's in the...
In the salad.
Oh my god.
Oh, cute!
Cute, cute, cute.
There's Ollie somewhere too?
Okay, we'll find her.
Old man.
Frog man.
Kero kero bento.
Vtuber energy drink.
Did you guys drink a vtuber energy drink?
I mean, we have vtuber potato chips.
I'm surprised there's not...
Oh, wait, we missed one.
Surprised there's not vtuber energy drink.
Imagine being a frog man.
Couldn't be me.
Shio daichi.
Mmm, sweet coffee.
Sweet.
I don't know why I couldn't pick up the other...
Oh, this one's cute.
This one's really cute.
Couldn't pick up the other...
That blue train though, earlier.
Cute.
Oh, just some delicious water, of course.
Gamer.
Gamer bento.
Mint G Fuel win.
That was cute.
So cute.
There's so many.
Oh my gosh.
No one's gonna find me.
If you have to go through all of these.
Mortis.
If I were to get one, no one would find me.
I think.
Right?
Cute.
I like that design.
Oh my gosh.
So cute.
Otome bento.
Hidden one.
We won?
You find me?
You won?
Cute.
Chocolate.
Matcha.
Oh.
Wowee.
What's the floor mean?
We're in seat 13.
Oh.
Gachiman.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh.
Pookie.
I like her art.
She has a webtoon that I read.
That's so funny.
This is the last place I expected to see her.
For free?
What's for free?
Cute.
Looks like.
Looks like a Cinderella girl's.
Like.
Card.
You know?
A ghost.
Me too.
Oh gosh.
That guy scared me again.
Oh.
This guy's got nothing.
This is economy class.
All these people affording these bentos.
They're crazy.
Cute.
Fun.
I like the eye patch.
Cute.
A mama.
Oh.
Cute.
The most dangerous sniper.
The most dangerous bento.
Yeah.
These people just getting their normal ass faces.
Like.
At some reason it's like totally normal.
To see the Vtubers at this point.
Because Vtubers are in like every single one of these games.
But seeing like the people.
With just their normal photo.
Like their facebook pics are just so funny to me.
I don't know why.
It's like.
It's just.
It's just, it takes me out of like the immersion.
For some reason.
What is it?
I don't know why.
Oh!
There she is!
There's Ollie.
That's not Ollie.
That's all of them after this.
Cute.
Very rosy.
Lemonade!
Oh, nope.
Just kidding.
Sorry.
I almost missed some people.
Hello.
Is this a horror?
Horror bento.
What could be in there?
Aizuki.
Makes me want some.
Oh, wait.
We did see this guy.
Is he the old man?
You think?
Is he the old man that we talked to earlier?
Maybe.
Cat.
Okay.
Very good.
Glad we could see him.
See all of those.
He's running.
Oh, is he running for parliament?
Oh my gosh.
I was gonna say.
That'd be so crazy to see an actual politician in my video game.
Oh, wait.
We missed these ones.
I think.
Oh, no.
Just kidding.
I remember the rainbow eyes.
Okay.
You on the next one.
I will...
Subscribe to the Patreon.
Like...
Well, I was gonna say right after this, but I'm starving.
My stomach is like...
I'm hungry ghost right now.
I'm hungry ghost.
So, I'm gonna go haunt some of your guys' houses.
Please leave out some snacks for me to nibble on.
I'm gonna house hop.
And, uh, you know.
Just some, like...
Some offerings for me.
No, not cookies.
I'm looking for something with a little bit more substance, probably.
Yeah, I would like some offerings.
Um...
Sorry.
I would talk afterwards, but my stomach is actually getting upset.
I can't tell if it's upset because I'm hungry or if it's upset.
Upset.
I don't know.
Tummy heart.
I'm so sorry.
A sandwich.
Yeah!
A sandwich would be perfect.
Oh my gosh.
When I was in Japan, I lived off of eggy sandwiches.
I love the ones...
Okay, there would be, like, egg sandwiches with cucumber and ham in them.
It was...
Oh my gosh.
It was so delicious.
Because it was just the right amount.
I don't like a lot of ham.
It was just the right amount of ham for me.
And I like a lot of cucumber, unfortunately.
It was kind of slacking.
I'll be honest.
Kind of slacking on the...
On the...
Cucumber.
But that's okay.
I could still taste it a little bit.
I have left out some durian for you.
Maybe I won't go to your house, kinky cadaver.
I just had some spaghetti.
No reason.
What do you mean, no reason?
It was super obvious, but the plant car was the coolest thing I've seen in these types of games.
Yeah!
It was really cool.
It, like, felt...
Oh my gosh.
You guys know that game Tokyo Jungle?
It felt very much like that.
Maybe I can play that.
Tokyo Jungle.
That's a fun game.
I don't know if I've seen anyone ever stream that one.
It's kind of older, though.
Wild Pomeranians.
Yeah!
Give me Tokyo Jungle.
Oh, gosh.
My stomach.
Okay.
It just all of a sudden started hurting.
So, luckily I was able to get through the game.
I was hungry earlier, but now it's starting to hurt.
So, I'm going to end it early.
I'm sorry, guys.
I don't mean to end it early, but I'm going to go.
I'm going to call it here.
Thank you guys for hanging out with me today!
And...
Yeah!
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you!
Go eat, ghost girl.
I will.
Hungry ghost.
Otsuminto!
I will see you guys.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my gosh.
I did totally intend on sticking around and talking, especially because this is only two and a half hours, but at least we got...
I assume we got all the endings.
Right?
I'm assuming that there's only two endings.
We got all of them.
I think.
It's okay.
Thank you guys for understanding.
I'm going to go get food.
Otsuminto.
Yeah.
Yep.
Just two endings.
Oh!
I didn't get caught!
Oh no!
There's no more?
I can't tell what you guys are saying.
Cool.
Get out of here.
Okay.
I'm leaving.
Bye bye!
Otsuminto!
Otsuminto.
Hold on.
I'm going to wave to you guys.
Otsu.
Otsuminto.
Bye bye!
Thank you for all the...
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Thank you for the stream!
You want this tub of chocolate mint ice cream?
Sure!
At least the tummy hort can't kill you again!
So true!
Thanks for the stream!
Thank you!
Thank you for the stream!
Okay.
Otsuminto.
See you later.
See you.
When I see you.
Next stream is...
Yippee!
Bye bye!